you know I think these days just Muslim
cuz you know if you click Sydney you
might be Isis you don't want to go yeah
okay so we're trying to create this
profile and we can click a bit of fun
username right I think sexy must climb
is appropriate Oh how old are you 39 so
you're like ethnic 50 so I would say
yeah 21 I didn't a mom of three things
you'd like in your significant other I'm
looking for a religious non gun-wielding
non wielding sheikh who is also
comfortable with occasional clubbing
there's occasional oh yeah I didn't
think that I shake the dead dump cannot
smell like hurry we smell like our
favorite Arabs we have solid what are
you here for
that's my find to get married yo God
willing we will find a match yes
okay I have to say a third of my friends
are seriously looking on these dating
apps or it's hard finding a partner in a
country which is actually a continent
like the United States you know where
our communities aren't as as closely
clustered as they are like back home
whether it's Pakistan or India or dojin
really defines who we are and it's part
of our identity and it's definitely not
something you can swipe left or right
preferably right because it's the way of
a song that's the way of this month